what if I told you that using cardboard
in the garden is a terrible idea it
doesn't kill weeds effectively it
doesn't feed the soil and it does
absolutely nothing to improve your soil
Health after years of trial and error
I've developed a system that not only
eliminates weeds but builds living
thriving soil without a single piece of
cardboard My Method uses cover crops as
a natural sheet mulch with roots still
in the ground creating a weed-free
garden while boosting biodiversity
improving soil structure and drainage
while Scavenging for nutrients bringing
them to the soil surface locking them in
and making them plant available for
healthier plants and bigger harvests
with no fertilizer cardboard just
Smothers the ground but cover crops feed
the soil their Roots break up compaction
support soil microbes and add organic
matter where it matters the most below
the soil surface in this video I'll show
you exactly how to build the ultimate no
dig Garden using cover crops as a sheet
Mulch and why cardboard belongs in your
Rec cycling bin and not in your garden
hey what's up everybody welcome back to
Chef's Harvest Farm if you're new here
I'm Chef Mikey I'm a former executive
chef turned Urban Farmer and I turned my
backyard gardening hobby into a thriving
no till Farm where I grow food
sustainably for local chefs and
restaurants here in Knoxville Tennessee
over the years I've tested just about
every gardening method out there made
mistakes fought the weeds and figured
out what actually worked over the past 8
years I've developed a cover crop system
that improves improves crop Health
eliminates weeds and builds healthier
soil without chemicals or cardboard but
it didn't start this way when I first
began gardening in my backyard the soil
is nothing more than hard compacted clay
like concrete that's why I started with
typical raised beds thinking nothing
would grow in my native soil but after
years of trial and error I developed a
system that transformed this into
Healthy Living soil and I'm confident it
can improve almost any soil no matter
how bad it is so how does it work it all
starts with one simple shift stop
thinking about how to feed your plants
and start thinking about how to feed the
soil I farm using nature as the model in
a forest nobody's fertilizing the trees
yet they Thrive leaves fall creating a
natural mulch the soil is never exposed
which is why you never see erosion
animals add nutrients plants break down
and nothing is ever removed it's a
self-sustaining system you never see an
entire Forest wiped out by pest because
there's balance where predators and prey
exist in harmony in contrast when we
only grow vegetables we create a buffet
for pests with nothing to keep them in
check that's why I use multi-species
cover crops they don't just improve the
soil they create an ecosystem
underground and above more plant
diversity means more microbial diversity
healthier soil fewer pests and stronger
crops with higher yields it's Nature's
Way of keeping things balanced and at
work I mimic this process using cover
crops and compost the result healthy
living soil that grows thriving crops
without synthetic fertilizers constant
maintenance are fighting against nature
Step One is preparing your garden PLT
and this is where most people get it
wrong why because they're impatient the
key here is letting time do the work
this isn't the fastest way to build a
garden but in my opinion it's the most
effective I start by laying down a
silage tarp and not any tarp it has to
be either a silage tarp or greenhouse
plastic and here's why these tarps are
UV treated to withstand the harsh rays
of the Sun and they're nonwoven which
means that they trap in heat and
moisture which is exactly what you want
the tarps I buy are 105 ft long and 24
ft wide I cut them in half to create
garden plots that are just over 50 ft
long this keeps all my garden beds
uniform at 50 ft now the size of your
garden isn't what's important what
really matters is that all of your
garden beds are the same size that could
be 50 ft 100 ft or whatever works for
you in your cont context but here's a
tip I wouldn't recommend buying a tarp
any larger than that they're extremely
large heavy and hard to move even when
they're cut in half but why does a bed
size matter so much in a moment I'll
explain exactly why this simple detail
can make or break your garden success
now these tarps are most effective In
The Heat Of Summer but I've even
starting Gardens using this method in
the middle of the winter if you want to
speed things up methods like flame
weeding before you tarp can help too but
here's the real secret to making this
work and it's a part that most people
Overlook it has to be wet under the tart
set up some sprinklers run them for an
hour before you tarp the plot this
creates a steamy environment that breaks
down plant material fast plus it tricks
weed seeds into germinating only to
suffocate because there's no sunlight no
oxygen and they're under extreme heat if
it's too dry under the tarp you'll pull
it back months later thinking the job is
done only to find stubborn weeds waiting
to take over now how long should you
tarp I highly recommend tarping for up
to a year for the best result but if
you're in a hurry you can get decent
results with as little as 90 Days In the
Heat of the summer if you want to speed
everything up even more use greenhouse
plastic instead of a silage tarp in the
middle of summer you can get results in
as little as 30 days but if you can I
still recommend tarping for about a year
trust me you'll thank me later once you
pull the tarp back don't make the
mistake of thinking the job's done if
you you see weeds like Bermuda grass
don't ignore them the tarp won't always
kill them completely I'll go in and dig
those weeds out that the tarp didn't
kill roots and all otherwise all that
hard work will be wasted step two is
planting the cover crop I broadcast the
seed directly on top of the soil when I
first started I use winter Rye which is
a great choice if you're just starting
out but there's a couple key things you
need to know to get it right first
timing is everything winter ride must be
planted by mid- October oober in my
climate and here's the catch you won't
be able to plant anything in those beds
until May of the following year why
because winter Ry can't be terminated
easily until late April or early may you
have to wait for it to form a seed head
but here's the critical part you need to
terminate it before it forms viable
seeds this is called the milk stage
because if you squeeze the seed head
you'll likely see a milky substance
inside this means the plant is at the
end of its life cycle and ready to die
but if you wait too long and it drops
seeds you'll be fighting winter Ry seeds
forever and trust me you don't want that
headache if you want something a little
bit easier to manage peas and oats are a
great option if planted by mid-september
they can winterkill naturally no
termination required but this timing is
key for the winter kill if it's not
fully mature by the time winter hit it
will not winter kill and you'll have to
terminate it using other methods in the
spring we'll dive into termination
methods in a moment but over time I've
learned that diversity in cover crops is
where the real magic happens now I use
13 species cover crop mixes inoculated
with mic rise and nitrogen fixing
bacteria to create the most biodiversity
possible the challenge with
multi-species cover crop mixes that they
all mature at different rates so if you
don't manage them properly some will
drop seeds and become weeds it took me
years of trial and error to get this
right once I've chosen my cover crop I
simply broadcast the seed right on on
top of the soil I like to time this
right before a good rain or even during
a rain I heavily overseed using nearly a
50 lb bag of seed on a plot that's only
about an eighth of an acre that's enough
seed to cover a full acre if drilled why
so much because when you broadcast seeds
some won't germinate some will get eaten
by birds and rodents and some will wash
away by the rain plus I want it as dense
as possible to block out sunlight
smother weeds and add maximum organic
matter and nitrogen to the soil if
needed I set up sprinklers to ensure
good germination and healthy
establishment then I just let time do
the work as the cover crop grows their
Roots scavenge for nutrients deep in the
soil pulling them to the soil surface
they attract diverse microorganisms each
playing a role in the soil ecosystem
creating a symbiotic relationship with
plant roots and fostering micro risal
fungi connections this helps plants
uptake nutrients and water more
efficiently making your garden more
resilient it's like building a living
support system underground once the
cover crop reaches maturity it's time to
terminate it I use a simple tool a toost
tied to a rope to crimp the cover crop
down tied to a rope and I'm just going
to take it up I'm going to go like this
I'm just going to step on it and I'm
just going to keep moving all the way
down and crimp the whole thing right
down to the ground and I'm going to
start on like the edges I'm going to go
down the edge and crimp it in and then
I'll go down this Edge and crimp it in
and I'm going to leave the sprinklers in
place and crimp the whole thing going in
One Direction so I'm going to go down
one way and then I'm going to walk back
and then I'm going to go back down and
crimp it and I'm going to walk back and
then I'm going crimp it back so it's all
face in One Direction so that this way
when we pull the tarps over we pull the
tarps Over It All in One Direction and
it doesn't get snagged on anything but
here's a tip always crimp it in the same
direction that'll make the next step a
whole lot easier after crimping I pull
the tart back over the plot for two to
three weeks this ensures everything is
terminated and all the weeds that are
trying to come back are smothered out
but before I tarp again it's super
important to run the irrigation to
create that steamy effect just like we
did earlier this helps break down the
cover crop material into a nutrient-rich
sheet Mulch and it will force any weed
seeds to germinate under the tarp which
guarantees a weed-free start after a few
weeks we pull the tar back to reveal a
beautiful sheet mulch with the roots
still attached fostering a thriving soil
ecosystem but before we plant our cash
crops there's a couple more critical
steps so to recap we've prepped our
garden plot by tarping and eliminating
weeds planted a dense cover crop to
build soil health and let time do the
heavy lifting then we crimped the cover
crop tarped it again to create a
nutrient-rich sheet Mulch and now we've
got a living thriving soil ecosystem
ready for the next step now that we have
our sheet mulch With Our Roots still
attached it's time to measure and build
the garden bit before we start building
building out the garden bids I want to
quickly tell you about something that's
been a total GameChanger for my farm
finances I actually get paid to grow
cover crops through USDA Grant and my
secret weapon for securing those funds
is Farm raise they help farmers manage
bookkeeping for their schedule F keep
track of farm finances and most
importantly they alert you to USDA
funding opportunities and help guide you
through the process if you've ever felt
overwhelmed by Farm grants or didn't
even know where to start Farm ra makes
it simple and if you need extra help
they can even connect you with
experienced Grant Riders right now you
can get 20% off farm raay with my code
Chef
M20 don't wait you could be missing out
on free money that's sitting there
waiting for you right now I make all my
garden beds exactly the same size 30 in
wide 50 ft long with 18in walkways this
isn't just about Aesthetics it's about
efficiency I keep every single bed the
same size at both of my Farms why
because it makes everything 100%
interchangeable my drip lines insect
Nets silage tarps shade cloths and frost
blankets are all exactly the same size
no guessing no hunting around for the
right piece I can just grab whatever I
need and it fits perfectly every time no
wasted time looking for the right piece
now the exact size of your garden beds
isn't what's important what matters is
that they're all the same size once you
realize how much time this saves you'll
never go back to Mark the beds I use
Simple Wood staks from the construction
aisle at Home Depot or Lowe's then I
grab a yard stick measure out my beds
and walkways and for perfectly straight
lines I tie tomato twine from one steak
to another outlining the garden beds and
walkways like a grid this might seem
like an extra step but straight uniform
beds make every part of farming easier
from planting to harvesting to
irrigation and let's face it the real
reason y'all watch my videos is because
the garden looks clean organized and
aesthetically pleasing once the beds are
marked I fill them with about 6 in of
fresh manure-based compost here's the
thing not all compost is created equal
you've got to do the research ask
questions do trials before adding large
amounts of compost to your garden some
compost has little and no nutritional
value and worse it can be contaminated
with herbicides or pathogens one of my
guys delivered 20 yards of compost and
so I'm going to show you how I'm going
to test it for persistent herbicide
potential so I'm going to fill a few of
these up with uh with compost I'm going
to take it home with me all right so I'm
back in my grow room I got my little
things of compost here and then I've got
sugar peas and then I've got some beans
too so I've just got the little pots
that I filled up over there and then my
compost one two hook them down into the
compost a little bit and then I'm going
to go water them in if they grow all
good we're good to go and if not then
and will be concerned but I've never had
it happen that that it wasn't good I
just uh I'm sharing best practices with
you and then so this is just like a heat
mat and a grow light right up there and
then we'll check back in a few days and
see what they look like all right y'all
so I'm back in the grow room here it's a
few weeks later this is what you want it
to look like and if they like grew kind
of distorted or like wonky kind like
misshaped leaves crinkly or like just
stunted and really didn't grow well at
all then you would be concerned so this
is the best test that you can do to test
your compost for herbicide contamination
I'm looking all good so we're going to
go and use this compost or actually we
already did this compost feeds the soil
and acts as a nutrient-rich mulch
keeping my garden beds practically
weed-free All Season yes it's a lot of
work to get to this point but the payoff
never weeding or fertilizing your garden
is priceless the compost adds biological
diversity to the soil ecosystem feeding
the beneficial microbes and creating a
thriving environment underground this
method feeds your soil boosts plant
health and keeps weeds in check all
season long and there's no need to worry
about erosion because your soil Is
Anchored In by the cover crops root
system holding everything in place the
dead plant material sits on top of the
soil acting as a natural protective
barrier on top of that it's covered with
a thick layer of compost shielding it
from the harsh effects of the sun wind
and rain it's a living system designed
to mimic the forest just like we talked
about earlier using nature as the model
Nature's been growing plants for
millions of years without cardboard
synthetic fertilizers or human
intervention now for the walkways I
usually put down wood chips right away
to suppress weeds and retain moisture
but in this particular plot we left the
cover crop residue as the walkway for
the summer because we direct seated
winter squash here why because winter
squash Vines out and covers the ground
choking out any weeds that might try to
come back there was no need to walk in
the roads no extra maintenance and as
you can see we had a great yield of
winter squash without adding any
additional fertilizer after harvesting
the squash we tarp the plot again to
suppress any leftover weeds added more
compost and filled the walkways with
wood chips now it's ready for garlic and
soon no dig potatoes if this blew your
mind or if you've got questions drop a
comment below I'd love to hear what
you're thinking and what works in your
garden thanks for watching grommies
remember to always work with nature not
against it and I'll see you in the next
one